only seven percent of Americans consider
themselves very liberal and probably
fewer of them consider themselves to be
woke and so you know when when we talk
about you would you mind defining well
could this come up a couple times and I
just want to make sure we're on the same
page
so
I mean woke is sort of the idea that
um
I
this is going to be one of those moments
that goes viral I mean well yes but for
a different reason than she thinks is
something that's very hard to Define and
we've spent an entire chapter defining
it no it is sort of guys you've got to
read a whole chapter to understand what
it is the understanding that we need to
re totally reimagine and re reduce
Society in order to create hierarchies
of Oppression to create hierarchies of
Oppression what are you talking about
Bethany sorry I it is hard to explain in
a 15 second sound bite but yeah